we have the story from the defense post
U.S dispatches warships after Chinese
Russian vessels Patrol near Alaska you
know with a lot of people being like why
are you talking about Megan Rapinoe and
cultural stuff we got real news here
the US Navy deployed four destroyers
after detecting Chinese and Russian
vessels conducting joint patrols at the
coast of Alaska Alaska Republican
Senators Dan Sullivan and Lisa murkowski
revealed in a statement that at least 11
Russian and Chinese ships sailed close
to the Aleutian Islands in the northern
U.S last week this prompted the U.S
military to deploy four destroyers and a
p8 Poseidon Maritime Patrol aircraft to
Shadow the vessels Rakowski explained
the incident served as a stark reminder
of Alaska's proximity to both Beijing
and Moscow
incursions like this are why we're
working so hard to secure funding and
resources to expand our military's
capacity and capabilities in Alaska and
why our colleagues must join join us in
supporting those Investments well I got
bad news for you your woke military is
unappealing people don't want to be
involved in it and so the best you can
probably hope for is automation
unfortunately
or drift
no I don't think the draft's gonna work
the draft would just ripped this country
and ripped this country to shreds well I
I hope you're right I think if people
were being threatened with prison they'd
have to make that decision yeah yeah
it'd be crazier than uh than than people
realize man I feel like a draft isn't a
realistic
um possibility until they actually uh
like until there's actually some kind of
combat like where you have yeah but the
American dudes getting into gunfights
I'm not just talking about like you know
how easy it is to false flag the people
into well yeah yeah but I mean I'm I'm
just saying that like I'm not saying
that that it's out of the question I'm
just saying that I think there are
things that have to happen before that I
agree with you that becomes a thing
especially if they were to announce it
tomorrow there would be absolute uproar
but if they were to announce it after
allegedly no you know no nope okay lay
it on come on dude name a scenario in
which the left and the right unify
give me a second you're gonna play hard
on this one because I don't see any
circumstance let's say Vladimir Putin
goes on TV and says fires in his house
and then he hits a red button and a nuke
flies half the country goes this is Joe
Biden's fault you did this it's your
fault the other half says we need to
rally the troops and go fight against
Russia no no unification and then if Joe
Biden calls for the draft people are
going to actively be like I have this
scenario it's been it's been fomenting
for quite some time actually because the
GOP and their voters have been convinced
that the CCP is their Arch Enemy so you
have some sort of leak that comes out
about the Wuhan Institute of virology
and the origin story there and and it's
now proven quote unquote simultaneously
Putin nukes Kiev
now you have the Catalyst uh from both
sides to be furious and accept it I'm
just a double a double false flag at
once come on I I don't think you will
get oh man I don't think you will get
you can maybe get a small portion of
conservatives but nobody's fighting for
Joe Biden you know why because Russia
could fire a nuke and China could admit
to the Wuhan lab leak and then Joe
Biden's gonna come out and be like we
need all of you to come together and and
and fight for this cause and
conservative conservatives are going to
say you actively support pedophiles and
I'm not talking about weird conspiracy
theories I'm talking about these books
in schools I'm talking about the groomer
events that these people are putting on
it doesn't matter what happens I can't
imagine a conservative being like you
know I know that Biden sniffs kids and I
know that the left actively supports
these sexually graphic books being given
to Children I'm gonna fight for those
people right not gonna happen well I
mean yeah I guess it would it would
require it would require loss of life
unfortunately I think it would be a
Pearl Harbor 911 type event I I you
don't think that would go absolutely not
wow people thought kovid would unite
this country yeah that that this massive
threat
in the first 60 days we were pretty
United in horror
yeah but we were not United in our
efforts together you had you had you had
the first the right was like everyone
should wear a mask and the left was like
No And then she comes out saying don't
wear masks and then all of a sudden a
few months later it switches like
there's no there's no unification of
this yeah well and if they were to if
they were to bomb yeah you're right I
probably wouldn't be that upset
depending on where it landed if if
another Pearl Harbor happened right now
there would probably be riots against
Joe Biden for having caused the
escalation by funding war in Ukraine see
that's interesting you say that because
I'm not at all convinced that the right
wing is capable of actually rioting like
January 6 was as close as they got and
that was pretty tepid no I I agree let's
let's let's break it down by actual how
things go
the US government then calls in a draft
of some sort right and then you get
massive conflict with people resisting
and rejecting police are going to be
split in half they're I mean cops are
already starting with a bunch of vote
policies but let's just put it simply
that if anything happened to this
country that resulted in hard military
action there would be
it would be Bedlam yeah you're not going
to get conservatives being like this is
the one issue where we've decided to
stand and salute Joe Biden never gonna
happen Okay especially when you look at
69 of Republicans believing that Biden
is illegitimate they will never salute
that man under any circumstances well
let me let me say one you make me more
hopeful and two uh to all of the
conservative listeners and viewers out
there I hope you're taking this to heart
if there is a draft for an immoral war
that is unjustified you have every Duty
not to go
and it's because look
when I talk to people who have resigned
their commissions or who are saying like
one of my one of my four years are up
I'm gone
they're blaming wokeness Yep they're
saying that these these policies are the
antithesis of what I'm what I wanted to
fight for and now I'm disgusted one guy
told me he wanted to be a career so now
he's resigning his commission and he's
leaving
there I don't see anything that's going
to make people on the right agree with
this yeah
what kind of uh military conflict do you
guys expect to see in uh well the South
Asian Sea right now several American
ships you know outside of Korea in
Australia take a look at this they're
not they're doing nothing yeah they
dispatched warships over the aleutians
people need to understand we're not
talking about the main body of Alaska
we're talking about the Illusions and if
you come down here to like ATU station
yo that's right next to like Russia yeah
it's equidistant between the two right
it's like
Alaska and Russia right next to each
other look at this you got St Lawrence
Island yo you're you're right there
and so if Russia and China are having
ships sail around the Bering Sea they're
going to be near the Aleutian Islands
where there's a whole lot of nothing now
to be fair a lot of our crab from
Onalaska that's where they do that show
about crabbing and uh don't mess with
our crab Vlad I think it's on no where
is it I don't know where Onalaska is it
here where is it at well I could
probably just type it in but they're in
the Illusions they get crap they do they
do the crabbing stuff there
so this is a huge stretch of violence
that goes all the way towards Russia
very close to Japan even well I
shouldn't say very close but it's like
look at this like I'll go close I mean
closer than what California right
oh yeah substantially very closely
comparably yeah and I think the Bering
Strait is like 50 miles or something
I mean not not far and fakes right here
who owns that Russia from her house is
that Russia oh no it's Alaska diamond is
Alaska big diameter who owns big
diamonds I've heard like these islands
you know there'll be scientists who go
back and forth and it's kind of this
weird diplomatic relationship because
they're studying similar areas
look at this there's no reason for us to
be enemies with Russia I've been saying
this for years it's so it's so
ridiculous is this for real diamond
island that's amazing it's beautiful wow
this podcast from there I feel like yeah
let's just uh let's just let's just
let's just go it's the winter for six
months I think that's one thing that the
America New Hampshire you can do it the
American people really aren't privy to
how much uh I don't know calm the both
the CCP as well as uh you know Putin has
has demonstrated towards the West given
How Deeply the West has gotten involved
in the war in Ukraine in terms of giving
them you know basically whatever
Weaponry they want there's now attacks
that are happening within within Russia
that are almost certainly from Weaponry
that's been provided by the West like
how I don't know how we can still
pretend as if this isn't antagonistic to
the point that they would be justified
in counter-attacking and I'm just so
grateful that it hasn't happened
the U.S commissioned their first Naval
vessel in Australia like last week and
we're just pretending like we did it for
fun no way we just like Sydney that much
like no obviously we did it for a reason
there's a reason why the first time we
ever commissioned a a naval ship outside
of the domestic Port was Australia it
was because recently China hello the
first wow yep you can worry about it on
Tim cast news oh really I got I gotta
read that website it's a really good
website it's the best in my opinion
that's what I've been told yeah it's not
as good as Casper but it's pretty good
well you know they do different things
to be fair
when was that when's that article from
I'll send it to you because I wrote it I
think it was like 48 hours because I
wrote it that's why I know about it
well I just pull it up
it's from I think a week ago maybe two
weeks ago at this point two weeks ago I
thought you said it was this week yeah
it was this Summer that was fake news
I was an inaccurate time is moving in a
crazy time is moving
um but it was it's the U.S USS Adelaide
it's named after a ship that they had
before at the Adelaide uh rescued I have
to read my own article again or do the
facts but it was an Australian ship that
rescued an American ship and so they've
named it in honor of it uh but again
this press release came out from the dod
and they were like it's so fun we just
you know had this ship and it was made
in Alabama and we sent it to Australia
and anyways we commissioned it
everything's fine don't ask any
questions can I tangent briefly because
I'm I'm really Disturbed that there
hasn't because I'm thinking about China
right now and I'm just so Disturbed that
there hasn't been additional follow-up
by this current session uh Congressional
session from the GOP in terms of
figuring out the origin story of covid
like is there going to be anything do we
know Republicans don't do anything so I
have the story from San Diego Tribune it
says the San diego-based Canberra will
become the first U.S warship
commissioned in an allies
it was Canberra right yeah I looked it
up and it's a combat ship this was uh
end of May so it's a couple months ago
was that a couple months ago that is
wild well I'm sorry I'm sorry no you are
right it was two weeks ago okay I was
gonna say there's no way I remember
uh the order was May the official
commissioning was July 22nd but the
story is from May yeah uh I sent you my
link to mine which was last week or two
weeks ago or whatever it was but I just
published the July 24th but it is
interesting that we have been talking
this was public the dod was saying we're
going to build the ship uh a diplomat
from Australia a state senator from
Australia came to Alabama and toured the
facility and now we're like oh yeah
everything's fine well what I find
fascinating is that it's so clear that
the the Taiwan issue is like the
military industrial complex of the of
the United States clearly wants this
conflict to escalate it whether or not
they actually want there to be a war or
they just want to be able to fill their
coffers and and create more Weaponry I
don't know which but what's interesting
to me is that it would be so beneficial
to them to figure out this Wuhan piece
of the you know in the ingredients in
terms of even if it were I mean if it
were true there'd be a lot of reason
that people would want to go to war with
China and if it's not true they would
probably want to flip it to propaganda
as the American people I think the
American people I think if if everything
gets out about what went on in the Wuhan
lab I don't think the United the
American people are going to be in any
position to demand the United States
going to war with China because I think
the United States had a lot to do with
actually doing that so the US blaming
China and being like oh we're gonna go
ahead and and have a military action
against China when the United States was
was at the very least neck deep in
funding and directing was was there ever
a time in this country where you could
just turn the TV on watch football
pull the lever on your recliner crack a
beer
wings at your side and that was life
because we like to sometimes imagine
that's the case but I don't think that's
ever been the case maybe for like a
brief period in the 90s but there's
always been something going on to great
degrees of escalation and I want to
point out too
I think after the fall of the Soviet
Union we did have this period sort of
where we owned the world oh yeah
figuratively but you know kind of not if
you know what I mean no it was pretty
literal I mean from 91 on you have the
US dollar Reserve currency that's just
totally dominant you've also now crushed
your primary enemy they're gone there's
everybody else is still kind of
recovering from World War II or or
different uh conflicts and it's like
there was no one that was even close but
the problem is is that we squandered it
we had almost no national debt we have
the dollar Reserve uh you know position
on the global scale and an economy
that's absolutely crushing it uh and we
just we just blow it all for nothing and
and we look back on it it's like yeah we
were in this time of peace and
prosperity and we traded it all for what
like what did we get for this I'm not
surprised though I'm not necessarily
these stories about that people win the
lottery and what do they do they buy
golden statues of themselves right you
know it's just ridiculous it's improved
but for the longest time it's like
people would win the lottery and they
would just buy nonsense they would do
dumb things now they invested and they
you know they they set up trusts and
things they have good lawyers because
there was this big like public there was
stories about you know Night lottery
horror stories about people's lives were
ruined by the lottery and then they were
like you guys need to get advisors on
this but what happens when you get a
generation in this country that is is
gifted we are the children of the
greatest Generation the Boomers uh I'm
not saying the boomers are the greatest
I'm saying quite literally the greatest
Generation who fights in World War II we
have we have a nation of veterans people
who see combat and then we get this
period in the 90s where Millennials are
are growing up being handed
to a certain degree this easy life
then we get a bunch of crises we get the
Great Recession you get a lot of bad
things kovid Millennials have seen some
uh some bad stuff right the issue though
is
imagine growing up in the Great
Depression
when you're an adult you're grateful
you're like things are good no matter
how bad they get you grew up in the
depression then also you get World War
II and you're just like hey look man
I've seen some stuff right Millennials
were born into the most beautiful time
with parents being able to provide for
them in ways on average not everybody
but on average better than we've ever
seen
now they're all entitled they were
handed this gift they squandered it and
now they're entitled and angry well and
and
to in their defense there has been a lot
of mismanagement particularly through
their adult years that has been uh given
them given them serious reason to be
upset I mean from the 08 banking crisis
that was largely a Fed created Fiasco
but then the the lockdowns it's largely
well it's not entirely there's there was
still there was still Fannie and Freddie
that were packaging up uh you know
Triple B garbage and selling it off as
AAA so like there's you have a Fannie
and Freddie that was that was it's a
government entity I know I know but
that's not the Fed so okay okay all
right so all right my my bad I
misunderstood you I thought it's almost
entirely a government phenomena I want
you to blame the government
he doesn't want you to come on the show
unless you're fully blaming the governor
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time